hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to plague and gevalt
I just had to play some more because I
really really love this game and I have
a lot of fun so now we're onto fungus
now fungi are very different because
they're not good at traveling so I
always do an ATP boost anyways because I
like to have more at the beginning
because it allows me to do more anyway
but with this so what you need is you
need a lot more time to conquer the
world so it's gonna take longer just cuz
it's gonna take longer for things to get
out and about but that doesn't mean that
you stop being aggressive with it you
need to be aggressive with it you have
to be because if you don't then it's
gonna die
so I believe that fungi actually spread
really well in moist environments so
water is actually gonna help with that
but it does not do well in drying so
this is pretty much a thing of that it's
something tell stories I think I
actually like this one easier to cure
which is offset by genetic maybe oh good
oh goody good let's do this mega brutal
oh that's not a good name he would be
where the chanted grundle find murdered
oh I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I could
make myself laugh because I'm sure no
one else is okay so we have the grundle
fondler which is a horrible fungus it's
gonna kill everyone on the planet
because why not okay so the grundle
fondler comes from egypt the horrible
horrible egyptian curse the horrible
mummys curse the grundle fondler oh my
god I am an idiot okay so here we go
so with fungus what you have is you have
spore bursts which is technically your
way of spreading the spores around now
if I had ability stasis which would
prevent ability costs from increasing I
would get that because that would be
much more easy because there's a lot of
active abilities to use
with that being said I'm still gonna go
for maximum effective 'ti on symptoms
which is probably good I don't know
maybe so that doesn't mean that it can't
go on boats it actually can and a fancy
thing about this is they've actually
discounted a lot of these travel genes
because it thinks they're not as
important well that's bull they're very
important it just has a tougher time so
with the fungus you kind of got to fly
under the radar for a bit longer
you can't just go immediately into the
severe or else you'll die
so the grundle fondler definitely needs
to bite it's time hiding in the shadows
of your shorts hiding in the crevices of
your crack hiding in [ __ ] I'm either
loopy because I've been recording a lot
today or this is actually funny and I
really hope it is because other people
better back me up on this if it's not
funny I've got a problem
there we go mostly harmless no harm in
this one don't worry about the grundles
onler it's just it's a friendly hug of
the grundle I actually kind of forgot I
haven't played these other types of
diseases in a long time so it actually
is kind of new to me cuz I sometimes
forget exactly how it happens yeah I'm
not gonna make it I'm not gonna make it
iron you know I'm not gonna make it
because I'm a failure grundle fondler
not as strong as I thought need to work
on by fondling skills where my grundle
skills not on a witch damnit this okay I
did it wrong I did it wrong I did this
very wrong I did it wrong what I didn't
do what or what I was sports [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
the grundle fondler has been eradicated
damn it
damnit let's try this again the grundle
fondler will rise again I'm going in the
UK because UK is a rich country so it'll
slow down the spread of it inside the
country I definitely need to focus more
on the traveled things because I was
buying symptoms I'm a Vidya that's
stupid it's gonna infect quickly no
matter what it's only a few countries
left Bravo 11 Jesus this is why you need
the ability costs don't increase one cuz
holy hell damn it
the cure for a grundle fondler has been
deployed worldwide that's just [ __ ]
okay there's one thing that I definitely
need to be able to win this mega brutal
I'm almost positive that I need um
something else I need bit I need the
trans stasis no ability pathos stasis
that's what I need so I just need to
play the game a few more times I
actually I just need to play it one more
time and unlock that so that's what I'm
gonna do move but coming back both my
gonna kill buffa is deadly
okay boof but kill the world again I'm
good at what I do booth but eradicates
all humans ray everyone's dead but now I
got pathos stasis and pathos stasis what
I'm gonna need to be able to beat fungus
on absolutely the best cuz that's what I
am I'm the best oh yeah okay now watch
this boop boop they all costs less
dammit they still cost more I'm an idiot
never mind then oh that's right I forgot
I'm
yeah because in the middle I was
supposed to be doing one circle at a
time and not both because if you did
because it releases a big explosion that
does a whole bunch at once oh that's
right I forgot
I'm an idiot oh here's much I was so
dumb boom ba-ba-boom see five five at
once that's what I was supposed to be
doing but I wasn't doing it because I
was dumb
Frick okay so now who send them to do
birds now I can focus on a little bit of
ability because I got enough of a head
start so that I can do what I need to do
damn it damn it
dagnabbit damn it I fudged up again damn
it
yeah I did better the last time damn it
dagnabbit diamond I know what I gotta do
I know it I know what I gotta do get
back to pasture stasis dr. grundle
fondly will not beat again
hey deke don't beat me I am the grundle
founder I'm the one who fondles dude I'm
the one effort wait a minute why is why
is this not increasing now did I not
have it selected last this is what I
thought was okay all right I apparently
I didn't have it active the last time
because something went horribly wrong I
do
know why where you go okay that's what's
post that's I was I was wondering I was
wondering what was going on it was a
little bit silly I the grundle parlor
will not be fooled
yeah this is much better okay
all right see this is how it was
supposed to happen it was supposed to be
like this and not like the other crap
that it was cuz it was crap that's for
damn sure that's what it was
oh no no no no no no no god dammit why
did it run out of points ah [ __ ]
well okay alright now that I know now
that I know what's happening because I
don't know why it was happening like
that but apparently I didn't hit pathos
aces huh
dum dum Oh a little bit that now the
grundle fondler will reign supreme
finally everyone in the world is
afflicted with a grundle wander they
will know true pain maybe I can still
lose it but this looks better
hmm I mean not better for them but
better for me darkness shall fall under
the grasp of the grundle fondler he
hides in the hosiery of your dream key
he hides in the darkness of your drawers
he hides in the parts of your pants he
hides in the trough of your trunks he
hides in the bulge of your bloomers I'll
stop now
this is stupid I'm gonna win it's about
damn time I don't know if that actually
took a couple tries I don't know why I
didn't go at first but the grundle
fonder he's in stupid or something in a
new hey hey everyone's gonna day thanks
dariya yeah come on now and dead yay I
did it I achieved my goal the grundle
fondler has eliminated all life so now
is fungus on mega brutal that was
actually pretty challenging and you can
see without the pathos stasis is almost
impossible to do I highly doubt that
anyone would be able to do that without
the pathos stasis but if you can let me
know in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
by matter the audience drunk or high or
something and you're an idiot like why
would anyone listen ever what the [ __ ]
no do that oh he's so cute
he's too cute i with you and go to hell
and die he took you